LET'S GO TO VICTOR BLACKWELL AT
THE VOTING DESK WITH NEWS ON
ARIZONA AND NEVADA.
>> LET'S CHECK OUT WEST.
TWO OF THE FOUR STATES WE'RE
WATCHING FOR QUESTIONS ABOUT
CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
AND IN MARICOPA COUNTY, OF
COURSE, AS JOHN JUST SAID, 61%
OF THE VOTES THERE IN THE STATE
WE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE COMPLETED
THE DAY OF VOTING, BUT RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE WORKING THROUGH, SORTING
THROUGH THE EARLY BALLOTS, THE
BALLOTS DROPPED OFF.
ACTUALLY VIDEO TWEETED BY THE
MARICOPA COUNTY ELECTIONS
COMMISSION OF THE MACHINES
SCANNING THE SIGNATURES OF THOSE
BALLOTS.
WE HAVE VIDEO OF THE MACHINERY
WORKING TO SHOW THEY ARE
SCANNING THE BALLOTS.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL HOURS.
THEY'LL COMPARE THE SIGNATURES
ON THE BALLOTS TO WHAT THEY HAVE
ON FILE TO DETERMINE THE
VALIDITY OF THE BALLOTS, THEY'LL
BE ADDED TO THE COUNT.
WE'RE TOLD WE WILL NOT GET AN
UPDATE FROM MARICOPA COUNTY
UNTIL THIS EVENING.
NOW IN NEVADA, THE QUESTION IS
WHEN WILL WE GET THE VOTES FROM
THE DROP BOXES?
WE KNOW THAT IN CLARK COUNTY
HERE IN THE SOUTH, WHERE LAS
VEGAS IS, WASHAU COUNTY IN THE
NORTH AND DOUGLAS COUNTY, MUCH
SMALLER, WE HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
LATER TODAY OR TOMORROW TO GET
THE VOTES.
NONE OF THE VOTES FROM THE DROP
BOXES WERE COUNT ON ELECTION
DAY.
SO WE'RE STANDING BY TO ADD
THOSE TO THE OVERALL REPORT.
>> TO SUM UP WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING, BE PATIENCE.
>> EASY.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LITTLE
WHILE.
>> THEY HAVE A LOT MORE TO DO
HERE, A LOT TO COUNT.
>>> NOW BACK TO MR. JOHN BERMAN
AT THE MAGIC WALL.
NEVADA.
>> THE REPUBLICAN WITH A 22,000
VOTE LEAD.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT THE MAIL-IN
BALLOT IN CLARK COUNTY.
HOW MUCH MAIL DO THEY HAVE TO
COUNT?
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
BALLOTS THEY HAVE.
CLARK COUNTY IS A BIG COUNTY,
LAS VEGAS THERE, 75% OF THE VOTE
IN THE STATE IT MAKES UP.
THIS IS A COUNTY THAT JOE BIDEN
WON BY 9 POINTS.
KATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO MAY BE
UNDER PERFORMING.
SHE HAS A FIVE POINT LEAD THERE.
IS THERE ENOUGH TO MAKE UP THE
REST SHE NEEDS TO IN THE STATE.
IT HAS TO IN CLARK COUNTY.
LOOKING AT THE MAP IT'S THE ONE
SHE'S LEADING RIGHT NOW.
THE OTHER COUNTY WITH THE SECOND
LARGEST POPULATION, SHE'S
TRAILING ADAM LAXALT BY 5
POINTS.
SHE MAY NOT BE TRAILING WHEN THE
COUNTING IS DONE, DEPENDING ON
HOW MUCH MAIL IS LEFT TO COUNT.
BUT SHE NEEDS TO GROW HER
MARGINS IN THE MAIL, JUST WHAT
VICTOR WAS TALKING ABOUT THERE.
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME
TO COUNT BECAUSE THE MAIL IN
NEVADA JUST NEEDS TO BE
POSTMARKED BY ELECTION DAY, IT
CAN ARRIVE TODAY, TOMORROW,
FRIDAY, AND THEY'LL COUNT IT
UNTIL SATURDAY.
THIS COULD TAKE TIME IN NEVADA,
LET'S GO TO ARIZONA WE WERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
RIGHT NOW HERE'S THE LEAD, YOU
CAN SEE MARK KELLY, THE
INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT WITH A LEAD
OF 6 POINTS, JUST 67% IN
MARICOPA COUNTY, 61% OF THE
VOTE.
THIS SORT OF MIRRORS HIS
OVERALLSTATE LEAD, BECAUSE IT'S
THE BIGGEST COUNTY, ALSO A SWING
COUNTY, DEMOCRATS WON IT, JOE
BIDEN WON IT, THE MAIL-IN BALLOT
WILL BE COUNTED -- VICTOR TOLD
US WE WON'T GET ANOTHER UPDATE
UNTIL TONIGHT.
>> WEDNESDAY NIGHT.
>> YEAH, IT IS WEDNESDAY
MORNING.
SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO KNOW MORE
UNTIL TONIGHT.
WE MAY NOT KNOW MORE ABOUT
ARIZONA.
PATRICIA MURPHY WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHAT THIS MEANS OVERALL.
IF WE DON'T KNOW MORE ABOUT
NEVADA AND ARIZONA, WE DON'T
KNOW WHO CONTROLS THE U.S.
SENATE BECAUSE LOOK, IF IT STAYS
LIKE IT IS AND AGAIN, COVER THIS
UP, IT WOULD BE 49 SEATS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, 50 FOR THE
REPUBLICANS, IT COMES DOWN TO
THE RUNOFF IN GEORGIA.
IF SOMEHOW DEMOCRATS ARE ABLE --
IF KATHERINE CORTEZ MASTO
RETAKES THE LEAD IN NEVADA, IT
WOULDN'T MATTER IN TERMS OF
CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
>> EVERYONE IS LIKE, OH.
>> I KNOW, I DIDN'T KNOW THERE
WOULD BE MATH THIS MORNING.